Speaker 1: There is a bizarre new interview.
I have never seen anything like this with
Infowars conspiracy theorist Alex Jones. This is
the first interview that I'm aware of that Alex
Jones has given since the nearly $50 million
verdict. Remember that the attorney for the
plaintiffs in the Sandy Hook defamation case
against Alex Jones, Mark Bankston, joined me
a couple of weeks ago. We talked about a bunch of
different aspects of the trial. Alex Jones has now
given an interview to Andrew Callahan from Channel
five. It almost seems like an act. So I mean, this
is the way that I would say it. This is either an
act or very serious mental illness. By Alex Jones.
I don't know which one. Maybe you can figure
it out, but he seems very ill to me saying
he killed the victims of Sandy Hook.
Speaker 3: Do you feel responsible for what.
Speaker 2: Happened to the Sandy Hook families?
Yes, I killed the children. But beyond that,
no. I mean, I went in that school, I pulled a
gun out. I shot every one of them myself. I mean,
I'm guilty. Sure. You know, but I don't know.
It's just do I feel responsible that someone
on on the play video games on a bunch of drugs
went and killed a bunch of kids and then the
Internet questioned it and I covered that. No,
I don't feel responsible and I don't apologize
anymore. I'm done. I don't apologize. I killed
the kids. Was there a definitive. No, I killed
him. I killed him. He didn't kill him. No, I
didn't. I didn't know. Everybody said no, no,
I killed him. I killed him.
Speaker 1: Now, listen,
if I all of a sudden had to come up with 49.3
million, I'd probably be stressed out worse
than this. But he seems very, very ill.
Speaker 2: I already built it. I didn't.
I killed him. I'm the bad guy. I'm the devil. Get
ready. The First Amendment was one of the topics.
I don't think I killed him first. Then that killed
him. Get rid of the Second Amendment. Get rid of
the First Amendment. They're bad. They killed the
kids to George Washington killed him. Jesus killed
him. The whole thing. We should rename the whole
planet Sandy Hook. Everything should be holidays.
We should foul five times a day. Add it to New
Haven, Connecticut. For the kids who die, every
American's to blame. Everything on who's to blame.
I'm to blame. We are all guilty to Bloomberg and
Soros. Turn our guns in. Turn our guns n. I know
how to get it. I killed them. I killed them.
I killed them. I know I killed them. So I'm done
talking about it. I killed them. But we're talking
about the trial at all. There's nothing to talk
about. Let me tell you, I don't know if I can do
this interview right now. Yeah.
Speaker 1:
All right. And then he then he walks off. So,
listen, is that an act? I don't know. It seems
like he's pretty ill is my instinct. And it's
also understandable if you just had a $50 million
judgment against you and there are more cases and
more trials to come and more death for me, I mean,
to some degree, I would expect that he wouldn't
be doing well. But it really is a mishmash of
a lot of different things. And as Attorney
Mark Bankston told us when I interviewed him,
there are many more plaintiffs and
many more defamation cases coming. So
I don't know whether this is going to be really
the end for Alex Jones and Infowars. I mean,
remember when he was kicked off of YouTube, etc.?
We were told that will be the end. But then he
fundraised off of it. And then they keep making
money and they keep going. So I don't know if
and what the end is actually going to be, but in
the immediate, I would be curious to hear from you
what we just saw. Do you believe that
that is an act? Do you believe it is real
and a mental illness, or do you believe
something else? I guess that it's real and
normal given the circumstances. I don't know.
Let me know your thoughts and we'll follow up.